chapter eight
one infinite Creator it is true we are
one infinite Creator expressing himself
and I would arguably say that's what
we've been trying to say the whole time
we're just kind of inching towards it
because that's important because you in
understanding you need a process the
process is what allow it's like
um the grit of it it's the it's the
texture
the process is the texture of of your
actual Fabrics nice yeah yeah yeah and
and I couldn't
10 years ago somebody said you're one
infinite Creator what like okay so I
needed the same process yeah we all do
yeah and we're what we're doing is we're
trying to make it simple for you guys so
you don't have to go through the long
process that we have to go through but
essentially we do gotta or some there
has to be some sort of process so you
can really understand yes because when
somebody just tells you it can you just
it rolls off it rolls off because it's
not sticking to any foundation and the
foundation of self-inquiry that we're
aiming to uh communicate to you that
then you take an you take ownership of
Investigation as the foundation of your
own journey of self-inquiry yeah that's
the core part because now you're the
investigator you're a permanent
investigator yeah and now moving forward
um
you're constantly not only on your own
uh investigation of self-inquiry but
you're kind of like this
I I guess how could you it's like uh
when you move through reality after
you've taken on this investigator role
and investigated with self-inquiry
into I now you're as you move through
reality you begin watering seeds yeah
and it's like a shedding
yeah and so now it's like yeah wherever
you go another way to say it is maybe
you're like uh you're emanating or
you're Illuminating I like that way
better yeah yeah emanating and
Illuminating yeah yeah everywhere and so
that like even that little like smile of
knowing I while you're at the checkout
at the store like and you're like
thanking the other person you're coming
from that energy of knowing that that's
also I even that little interaction for
them can create a nice little Cascade of
like more happiness and more peace yeah
and that kind of thing and and it's all
about information comes in frequency so
that small interaction raising that
person's frequency yeah yeah who knows
who they talk to right after that after
that yeah and then they meet someone and
they suggest a book or you know whatever
movie yes yeah yeah and so then this
also really
um comes a lot when let's say
um
you're you're beginning to come you're
navigating reality more from the
frequency of I you're coming more from
the frequency of I at the same time as
your unique label as your unique
character now
um and this will have a we'll have a
we'll have a little a beautiful creation
of a of a short film that's coming and
also that will have more like this over
time but you'll see how
found and how gentle it can be to
nourish a little seed in someone else
when you were you were with sunny when
we were driving and you were when you
were talking to her you were talking
about it being a little
bit of light in the pinhole yeah
and that being just enough just enough
for someone to either speak truth or
understand truth yes yeah and so that's
all you need and that's again that's the
purpose of this book is to create that
pinhole for you maybe it wasn't there
and just through a few chapters you're
like okay so there's a little more to
life than what I saw in man to say that
there's a little more to life oh you
letting in a shitstorm the greatest
shitstorm you're gonna be swimming in
this
um but but yeah no like I said you know
understanding one infinite Creator this
goes back to like chapter two
um all is I so when we said that yes
that was it that was the end you know if
but again there's a process to this so
but if you understand that all is I in
everyone's eye then everyone is I and
then if we're assigning I to the
infinite Creator then everyone's
infinite Creator yes the name what does
that look like what does it look like
for a world or Society to have the
understanding that they're the infinite
creator
mind you again we don't know I have no
idea I can speculate I can say oh it
might be good or whatever but
and I it will be great but I can't tell
you exactly what it'll look like but I
know it'll be different than what we're
going through now
and that we're all looking for a
solution
we we feel it's panels we fill the
documentaries that's a lot of things but
to me it's just understanding
or lack thereof and that's a great North
Star is what does Earth look like when
all no they are one infinite creator
yeah
and so why not polarize your attention
and your choice your Mastery of the now
to that North Star right if you're
already this far into the book and into
the course
you are likely someone that incarnated
that is here on Earth for that mission
absolutely so dedicate all your time to
that mission absolutely yeah yeah it's
beautiful and and also another core part
of it that we wanted to get across is
that
are not free if you are not I oh man I'm
so glad you brought that up yeah
laughs
to to to not like you said let me make
it simple to not understand I
you're your name and then your name is
born in the city in a state in a town
and it has a race and those people act
like this and you go to this school and
they're like this it's so many boxes yes
but if you're I I has no labels I has no
boxes I has I don't even know what this
eye is all it's boundless boundless
limitlessness and then we had that line
because it's simultaneously boundless
and bounded right and that's the beauty
of it is that you're both box less and
apparently in a box called a costume
identity for a play yes and you know
this just leads to the Grand
contradiction that the Universe God
Source I is a grand contradiction
exactly and I think that's important to
say because don't let the contradiction
confuse you correct or or or or uh this
is Scourge you this is the gateway to
Enlightenment you have to say yes yes so
so recognize that quote freedom
is Liberation from the boxes being the
only identity
and that way then coming from box
lessness
you can also enjoy your costume identity
in the play freely freely that's Freedom
that's freely I have the awareness to
know that I'm in bondage okay now that I
know that let's go let's go
and when I choose to leave leave yes
because I know I'm bonded yeah and I
know that I'm box less and bound less
yes meaning I am totally cool like I'm
so cool like I know that imma be back
yeah I'm gonna be on
imma be on this
endless exploration this endless mystery
forever forever yes yes that's what
Infinity is and when you like really own
it really forever when you I mean
seriously like when you hone in on
Infinity
eternity forever when you really like
hone into that there's nothing you can
do but surrender yeah let go let go let
go and then dance through all creation
forever
so uh yeah that is chapter eight